-Welcome back.
-As I live and breathe,
I'm back.
-And congratulations
on a Pulitzer!
-Thank you.
-You did not have one of those
last time you were here.
-I did not.
I do not take that lightly.
A lot of very brave sources
did some very tough stuff, so...
-And I want to talk
about the work
you did to win the Pulitzer,
but I also want to talk about
this book that is
separate from that.
And I know -- We do a show
about breaking news.
we have to scramble
and cover things last minute.
-You do an incredible job.
-Well, thank you.
-I love a fake
press briefing, right?
-But you --
-You ask harder questions
than the actual press pool.
-I know. Thank you very much.
Thanks for pointing that out.
But this is a book.
This is a book.
And books have to be done
a lot longer in advance
than something that I would do.
And you actually, in real time,
sort of had to cover
the Tillerson firing
because this is about
Secretaries of State
and diplomacy.
And did you interview Tillerson
after he was fired,
for the book, or before?
-Tillerson, if he had any logic,
knew that he was going to
be fired on some level.
Maybe that's why
he's so frank in this book.
I mean, he basically says
"I didn't know what I was doing.
I wasn't experienced
enough for it."
Yeah, I set out to interview
every living Secretary of State.
I got there in the end,
but the problem with
writing about
this administration
is people are fired
every five minutes.
-Yeah.
-So it's, like,
rolling off the presses,
and I'm like, "Wait! Wait!
Stop the machines!
I need to add Mike Pompeo
to this book!"
-And you managed to.
-And I did.
-And that's interesting.
Again, it is very forthright
and frank,
the way Tillerson talks about --
It's almost like
an exit interview
where he admits
he deserved to get fired.
Were you surprised?
-He lays a lot of blame
on this White House.
I was not surprised
because it is apparent
to anyone looking at
the State Department,
which I was for this book,
that it's become something
of a Dumpster fire,
which is sad
because there are brave men
and women serving there.
And, you know,
what I lay out in this book
is it's unglamorous work.
It's not work that
people always understand
as much as what the military
does, but it really saves lives.
-And I do want to point out
that you do not lay
all of the blame
on the feet of Republicans
insofar of the State Department
right now,
that both Republicans
and Democrats have a problem
talking about the importance
of the diplomacy
vis-àà-vis the importance
of the military.
-Yeah, so, you know,
these are the people
that, yes,
stamp passports and stuff
but also screen dangerous people
and prevent them from
coming into the country.
They are the people who save you
if you're kidnapped abroad.
They're the people who cut
the high-level political deals
that keep our servicemen and
women out of the line of fire.
They're really important.
But because, you know,
they're not on the front lines
with guns making things go boom,
people on campaign trails
invariably kind of decry them
as dusty bureaucrats
who don't get anything done,
and that is true of both
Democrats And Republicans.
The Clinton administration
was terrible on this.
They slashed and burned
spending on diplomacy.
It was really bad for us
around the world.
It is happening now
to a new extreme.
But, yeah,
this is about both parties.
And a lot of Republicans
are in this book saying
this is a huge problem.
Colin Powell's saying
we're mortgaging our future
right now with this.
-You went and interviewed
an Afghani general.
Is that Dostum?
-General Dostum,
who is typically described
as a warlord,
although in this book
he says he is a peace lord...
-Oh, nice rebranding.
-...shortly before admitting
to dumping
hundreds, maybe thousands,
of Taliban prisoners
into a mass grave.
-Oh, my goodness.
-I don't know how that squares
with the peace-lord thing.
-And what was your takeaway
insofar as how his rise to power
in Afghanistan reflects
on U.S. diplomacy?
-So, one of the
interesting consequences
of kicking the diplomats and the
negotiators and the peacemakers
out of the room
is you end up with policy
that's made much more out of
the Pentagon and the CIA.
And there are
great people there,
and that's an important part
of how we do business,
but when it's the only part
you end up with relationships
like the one we have
with General Dostum.
Which is we gave him
a ton of guns after 9/11.
He went after the Taliban.
But then we're
kind of stuck with him.
And now he's the Vice President
of Afghanistan.
And I chronicle how
multiple administrations
covered up for
his human-rights abuses,
including this mass grave,
which he kind of admits to,
that his commanders did it.
And, you know, you meet him,
and it's pretty quickly apparent
that he's not necessarily
the kind of guy you want
to be lying down with.
-Yet when you met him,
he had a reindeer.
-He did have a reindeer.
-Yeah, okay.
You gonna explain
how an Afghani warlord
ends up with a reindeer?
-So, I don't know if you can see
in this picture,
but there's, like,
kind of flashing
Christmas tree lights
everywhere.
There's tchotchkes around.
Like, porcelain figurines
of horseback fighters,
which is what he does.
He has a sword,
and he's on horseback,
like cutting heads off
and stuff.
And, you know, this is like
his warlord sheik thing,
and I guess it fits that
he comes in with a reindeer,
and he sort of -- He gestures
to it like Vanna White
or something, like,
"Here's the reindeer."
You know, there's guys
with guns behind him,
so you don't want to offend him.
And it is --
It's a very nice reindeer.
-Yeah. And it's not
the reindeer's fault.
I mean, he didn't choose the --
But very sharp antlers
thrashing around.
So I'm, like, you know,
dodging the antlers and saying,
"Well, General,
what a lovely deer that is."
-Yeah.
Do you think he was --
Because you were an American
he's like,
'Oh, I know how
I'll put him at ease.
I'll show him the reindeer."
-Yeah. I think that's right.
It worked.
I felt very soothed.
-You were like,
"Oh. This is home."